[Musique]
haslem vote façon ça fait chaud au coeur
de vous voir alcon je vais vous demander
gentiment de vous lever de terre fou à
l'escaut et je vais vous demander
d'écrire avec vos corps chacun avec son
corps le mot vi v é e en commençant
semble donc vais aller et il faut
montrer le point du villa comme ça où
comme ça où comme ça et ça reste le e
bravo
ce que je vais vous raconter c'est ça
une histoire de vie une vraie celle de
moliens mognard jeu les rencontrer pour
la mer pour la première fois il ya déjà
quatre ans nous discutons beaucoup elle
et moi à chaque fois où je rencontre mon
lien je sens le besoin d'être là pour
elle et d'ailleurs je suis là entre
autres pour elle j'ai le besoin encore
une fois d'être là à l'ecoute avoir de
ses nouvelles et à comprendre et voir
comment elle passe ses journées
monia aurait pu avoir une vie ordinaire
mais elle ne l'a pas eu
elle s'est mariée très jeune et s'est
avéré que son mari était un consommateur
d'organes etc tables sont trop tarder
elle s'y met aussi à la consommation de
drogue
elle ne savait pas elle a consommé des
drogues plusieurs drogues et la finit
par perdre son travail
quelques mois après quelques années elle
a mis au monde deux filles après quoi
son mari a été diagnostiqué positif au
vih et à l'hépatite c est fini par
mourir quelques mois après il lui
demande de faire le test
monia et se retrouve avec une sérologie
positif au voyage est aussi à l'hépatite
c se retrouvent aussi dépendantes aux
drogues dépendantes à l'injection de
drogues à sa charge ses deux filles qui
commence à grandir qui commencent à
demander plus à voir plus de besoin elle
n'a pas de boule où elle n'a pas travail
mon et a passé trois ans elle me l'a dit
texto clair à acf que les phares à 3
mois 3 ramadan de suite fait chier à
l'art dans la rue dans un espace public
il ya des gens qui viennent lui donner à
manger de temps en temps sinon elle
galère
elle se bat chaque instant pour donner à
manger à ses à ses deux filles elle se
bat chaque jour pour ne faire pour ne
pas faire sentir que ses filles manque
de quelque chose manque et pour elle le
quelque chose c'est un n'a pas de toit
ses filles n'ont pas de papa n'ont pas
de quoi manger
monia n'a pas trouvé ont travaillé parce
que il ya la stigmatisation la
discrimination sociale
on sait tous surtout pour les tunisiens
qu'une personne qui est qui a le vih est
stigmatisé et discriminé
il n'a même pas le droit de vivre on
sait tous que parce que c'est une femme
tunisienne consommatrices de drogues qui
n'a pas de soutien qui n'a pas de
famille toute la famille toute sa
famille toute sa belle famille l'ont
abandonnée parce que elle a le vih et à
l'hépatite c parce qu'elle les
consommatrices de drogue
à ce coût pour eux et les délinquantes
ce coût pour eux et les travailleuses de
sexe
donc elle n'a pas le droit d'être avec
cette famille jusqu'au point elle a
travaillé comme aide ménagère et la
volée donc elle ne voulait rien que pour
acheter des nouvelles tenues à
l'occasion de l'aïd
elle m'a dit je veux mes filles vivre
comme les autres au moins une fois au
moins une fois
donc elle a volé elle était consciente
et elle s'est fait prix et à et a passé
quatre ans en prison
à sa sortie elle a trouvé ses filles en
abondance colère dans la rue avec
plusieurs pratiques à risques travail de
sexe pour les consommations de drogues
la fille aînée est décédé l'année
dernière la plus jeune étant présents
actuellement pour une peine de six ans
les sons harmonieux une petite fille de
presque six ans maintenant y'a pas que
que mounir je peux citer salle décidé
l'année dernière
ces mois de décembre 2016 à l'âge de 20
et 21 ans elle été consommatrices drogue
elle été abandonné par sa famille elle
aussi elle est décédée par une
tuberculose je peux citer d'autres
femmes najwa omayma pas seulement à
tunis à nabeul pas gaffe à gatlin où on
a des centres bounias est une personne
qui compte beaucoup pour moi et elle a
besoin de trouver sa place au sein de
nous dans son pays
je suis heureux de contribuer même très
peu améliorer la qualité de vie de monia
ainsi que d autres femmes et on a fait
un diagnostic communautaire participatif
ce diagnostic on le réalise quand on
travaille avec des populations
vulnérables
ce diagnostic nous a donné beaucoup de
besoins de ces femmes injecté rice de
drogue et tout de suite après je
constate qu'il ya un besoin énorme est
urgent d'avoir un espace de jours un
espace pour que ces femmes se retrouvent
et retrouve un minimum de dignité
j'ai eu beaucoup de témoignages qui me
disent j'ai oublié d'être une femme
tout à l'heure on peut rentrer dans les
détails si vous voulez elle oublie
d'être une femme et j'ai dit il faut
créer un espace cet espace j'ai tenu à à
le nommer les jasmins ça n'a rien à voir
avec la révolution du jasmin
c'est un espace qui été transcrit se
font en deux projets qu'on a rédigé
depuis 2009
cet espace les jasmins pourquoi les à
100 parce que ça m'inspire la joie à la
délicatesse
ça m'inspire aussi là ça me représente
entre autres la femme
la tunisie est cet espace là il offre
plusieurs services des ateliers
culinaires des ateliers théâtre
décidément on fait des projections de
films on prépare à manger ensemble on a
ce qu'on appelle les repas communautaire
donc on prépare à manger pour manger
tous ensemble une fois par parra par
semaine et et on a rajouté une activité
lebrun le mercredi matin
un conte fait on fait notre petit brun
ce mercredi matin et on essaie de
discuter il ya un atelier qui s'appelle
être une femme donc on essaie de de
faire revivre encore la féminité de ces
femmes et l'activité disons phare dans
ce centre c'est on a installé un salon
de coiffure
ce que l'hygiène corporelle le fait de
se coiffer faire manucure pédicure
teinture là un nouveau besoin c'est la
kératine donc on va essayer de répondre
à la kératine
j'ai eu tout à l'heure ma première danse
de kératine avec le truc là le lisseur
oh je sais pas qui est et et quelques
mois après on a constaté un nouveau
besoin ce qui est la prise en charge des
enfants dans quelles viennent avec leurs
enfants et les enfants en fait ils n'ont
rien à faire du coup on a essayé d'
aménager notre espace pour un espace
pour les enfants au moins un espace où
ils peuvent jouer un espace où peuvent
réviser un espace et c'était important
pour nous d'être les familles pour pour
ses enfants
et ce qui est impressionnant c'est que
commencer femmes milite résiste chaque
jour malgré la peine et la souffrance du
quotidien là je porte la voix des femmes
la voix demande et d'autres femmes
j'essaie j'ai essayé d'être à la hauteur
et elles m'ont donné un seul message je
vais leur demander qu'est ce que vous
voulez elles m'ont dit une seule chose
on a besoin d'être considérés comme des
êtres humains comme des personnes de
nous regarder
et merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]